我们今天的一个主题其实就是这边在大厂做研发对好我先简单介绍一下我自己吧对我自己的话目前在就是B站担任的是一个架构师的这样的一个角色然后我自己的话呃像是一个B站老兵对我可能一四年就加入了B站然后呃在过程中什么也都写对早期写业务也写过包括我们的开源的播放自然JK也写过技术架构
然后实际机身就什么都行那用一点可能算贬义的就是其实我自己自己就感觉上是个全战感觉现在说全战都像骂人的话我自己的话是IOS出身然后安卓和Web或者人都会一点点然后看我看我这背景也知道可能就是一个死来争恶心这样的一个二次元吧
那我今天的主题呢会分四部分大概去讲一下其实在海报里面说过我会先介绍一下一些现象那因为今天这个topic在做架构架构是一个非常非常大的一个那么我可能就会以一些就是就是很少的一些现象作为一个切入点对去去了解聊一下就是B站在这些问题中
一个什么样的思路解决以及一个一个什么样的观点以及什么样的具体的实践对我们先说一下就魔幻化就是有一句话或者说是其实已经滥输于所有研发同学的心理叫做说地内就是高内聚地友和对那高内聚地友和具体到底是个什么那比如说我们直观的根本感觉就是
ok 我把什么什么东西都写在一起就所谓的就是高内铸他一个东西能做什么所有的事情ok 比如说我现在就是一辆一辆一辆一辆特斯拉ok 我现在还能停一跃我还不止开车我很停跃我还能充电我还能干了anyway然后呢我和他是怎么呢我可能跟偏向于所谓的魔化化ok 我今天可以把像像未来一样可以把电池给换了我可以去把某一个部件我可以把轮胎给换了还不是
全部喊在一起假设啊比如说我现在以前是一匹马车ok我一匹马一匹马是不可能拆开的因为他自己本身就是一个生物那么话是这么说但是其实在过程发生过程中或者说每个公司看到了一些具体的现象其实就是魔花会有一个两级方法对我们先说掌握一个叫方法技巧如果首先怎么去做
高内GDO核的事情其实它是有一炮完整的一些技术方法论的而真正掌握这套技术方法的论的同学其实并不多我们先假设说OK我真的掌握了这些基本的知识能力那么我们还需要分一个东西叫模块类型那假设这个模块的类型是偏属于基础架构级别的这样的一种东西就是平音份层面的东西那还有一种OK我好像这个动画方式有点
有点OK 先说它模块类型如果它是一个偏音份级别的一个东西那么如果它是一个偏音份级别的东西那它产生的一个效果或者说最终时间出来的一个结果我们会发现它偏向于就是D内举而Bass的有和也就是D有和D内举D有和举个例子比如说我们网络库或者说是日治库它对它而言它其实是没有什么
那个很很高的我和的一些东西的那么他自己的内举能力更低因为他更偏向于是一个工具类级别的一个东西那如果说在我不懂我的就是这个高低内就是内举性偶和性相关的一些理论知识而言或者说他是一个模拟两可的状态我们偏向于我们的因为模块会写出一种叫做说高内举高我和的这样的一个状态也就是其实所谓的欧英文全部放在一起
那么在模块类型如果说它并且是一个偏APP业务的情况下它也会往这种方式来靠那么另外一种模式比如说就是这个模块类型它不偏不高不下在一个common级别的东西那么它会有非常多的一些中间的因素关联比如说我们工期是否是紧张了然后那个人的心情是否是爱
每个人都想偷懒或者说是懒其实是社会进步的一个动营那如果他不懒他今天的心情又不怎么不撤出他可能会写出一些地内局地有何的代码出来但是从大多数情况下我们一定会往下面的方向来走而这两种模型下会对我们的模块产生一样什么结果
比如说D内具D有合的这样的一个代码它可能见状度很高但是对它而言它使用程度是使用起来是特别不爽的那比如说高内具高无合的状态下OK它有可能使用起来非常快速但是它内部的迭代是一个非常差的一种状态我后面会举一个具体的例子那第二个现象是什么呢第二个现象这个是我从那个WDDC里面一期就是讲那个Data extension就是
那个基本的swift UI的基本数据的一张里我截出来的一张图它的描述语意义是什么呢就是黄线我们可以看到的其实是一个人类它的一个一个智利的一个水平嘛对我们可能从当年的古园里直到比如说现在我们的智利水平其实是在发展的但它可能偏向于一个比较平行的一个线性对比如说我可能我们跟100年前200年前的智利没差太多但是如果说但是一个复杂度
就比如说我们一个非常简单的一个一个数学共识Cnx和Cn2当n变大了以后它的负责度是一个一个函数一个指数级别的一个增长它并不是像人类的一个智力是一个线性的负责度那么当一个一个事物的事件数量比如说多到一定程度了那么它和人类智力的一个gap就是所谓的都就是bug
而这件事情其实是必然发生的这也是比如说我认为我们可能偏向程序员或者说我们是个研发我们一直要解决的一个问题就是怎么样让我们有限的智力去来去解决这样的一个指数就增长的这样的一个复杂度那第三个现象是什么呢第三个现象其实是这个样子就我也是个养猫的人对那猫你们跟人一样去要求他说OK就是
你不能尿床你得乖乖听话每天早上你得来起来叫我叫我起床对你又想着他怎么样但其实他就只是猫我自己也为他尿床过那么在这种情况下为什么我拿这个举个例子呢就是有一些模块或者说有一些团队他其实在团队的一个角色里面就是偏像猫这样的一个角色他可能日常会给你带来很多很多很多怎么说呢
带来很多快乐或者带来很多你的就是工作上的一些模块的产需要但是你又必须得不得不给他降低期望因为这是结合刚才第一个现象我们大多数研发同学从结果来说一定会写出的是高内学高物和这样子的一种业务逻辑代码那我举一个具体的例子我把比如说B站的一个场景或者说大多数
那个互联网现在都有的一个青少年模式的这样一个场景来拆我非常快速的会说一个这个这个这个模块如果说我们针对这个模块好好设计我该怎么设计比如说我们要设计他使用了一些调用你的场景然后我们要要管理他的一些导航器层级试图层级对对对非常多的事情但是很多其实我们会这么来写OK我就直接声明了
我有哪些場景可能被坦出這樣的一個青少年坦窗比如說我的推薦首頁我的視頻首頁ok我可以anyway任何別的from然後我可能寫一個非常非常簡單的一個方法就是static一個triple法那麼在這個方法裡面他就是你看他其實static他沒有上下文他沒有任何一切外部應該需要感知到的東西他沒有任何所謂的呃剛才在模塊畫中提到的
那个地友和他会在他的内部可能去import一些全局的window navigation他为什么会这么做其实他的对他而言他的心理就是ok我求求你了我全做了我对我而言比如说外部的一些沟通ok或者说别的一些东西比起让我自己内部写一个这么复杂的模块而言我宁愿自己去写一个这样的一个代码车而当你是一个比如说
一个架构式的这样的一个角色看到这样的一个模块你明明知道它应该怎么去裂带但是人性一定会倾向于变成一个很复杂很超级大的一个很偶和内居的这样的一个模块产生那么我们应该怎么来做这件事情这是第二套评就是我对解决这样的问题的一些坚持首先我在我看来就是一定不能去反人性就是很多
至少我了解我很多我認識的很多人他們會想盡一切方式去讓不管是行政手段或者怎麼樣的一些強制的手段要求就是所有的同學的模塊要去拆的乾淨又維生但其實這件事情本身就是一個就是從心理上大家就會抵觸這件事情更不可能去真實的去落地那對我而言我自己在
一个时间的过程中我只坚信或者说我只只一采用了就三条原则这是我认为的比较简单的三条原则第一条原则就尽可能自动化一切对什么都去自动化就像我以前可能玩的一个包括戴森球计划这样的一些游戏对那尽可能自动化一切他的后他他的背后的意义是什么呢他的背后意义其实就跟我们马冬我们陈旭元本身的一个呃怎么说呢本身的一个
一个一个优势就在一起比如说编码编码自己就是自动化一切的一个表现那第二种是什么的其实就是我自己认为有一些东西可能很多东西都需要争执的就比如说有一些同学觉得需要加一层来解决问题或者说减一层来解决问题或者说是重新来那么在我的看法里面就是所有的事情那么既然所有的计算机问题都可以用作业人解决那么我们就坚持使用这样的一个特点
加层最好的加层就是没有这一层最后一个点是我的一个坚持观点这是我自己比较喜欢的一个构建系统叫bezzle它自己的一个flogger叫fastcrypture2那么对它的语异是什么呢它的语异其实特别简单就是让结果可预测这也是我自己在移动端的一些框架设计里面去频繁使用到的一个准则就是可预测永远在确定的
在确定输入的情况下得到一定的输出那么它从比如说程序远这个角度之外也可以去扩散包括说你的技术方案在人力扩展等等这样的一些方式也运用这个准则那第二个我的原则是什么呢就是使用生命式变成对那么相对于一些偏那个过程时的
Presiduala的一个东西它两个的最关键只说明了一件事情声明是是saying what you wantPresiduala的一个模式是saying how to achieve it那这个很抽象这个我可能会今天不会展开讲因为时间也有限我可能会带一点这个思路在这里那么为什么会我会有这样的一个坚持在里面就是我们可以看到就是大厂的一个先进的时间从13年开始Facebook rex一直到22年
也就是最近的compose的正式的release我们可以看到四个技术站四个大前端领域上的最成熟的公司使用的方式就是这一套那么刚才都比较偏理论了然后我们可能来去给大家一起聊一下就是在实践过程中我可能是怎么使用刚才的一些坚持的一个思想去来
解决我看到的一些现象好,第一个对,第一个可能是B站目前使用的一个相对在国内相对小众的这样的一个模式,就是Model RapplesModel Rapples对应的其实是Polo Rapples或者是Mati Rapples多层酷对,那么我们先说一下就是为什么会使用Model Rapples对,那么
其实B站的大家可能看到的B站它是一个偏视频网站对应的一个app其实B站内部是一个偏平台性质的一个一个一个一个公司对它有什么它包括直播电商等等非常多的一些垂雷的业务那么在这个结构基础上我们展开了一些基础站会有一个什么样子呢
第一我们有超过100家的研发同学Develops然后我们有超过100个以上的便衣Units这个compileUnits指的可能是一个App比如说我们的bilibili粉的主App又可能说是一个直播机避检又可能是一个比如说偏单一功能的一个单元测试对有可能超过百个那么我们有超过百万行级别的来码code的代码
这些全都是业务逻辑代嘛包括我刚才说的一些垂类业务那么在底层的一些Library级别那么我们也有前级别以上的一些公共的CoolYouTube技术Cool那么同时我们还有一个非常大的一个跨屏台层因为我们有包括其实播放器然后一些剪辑因为视频等等相关的还有我们的渲染的内部引擎其实都是这一层超大的跨屏台层来做的
在这样一个非常一个巨大的一个code的模式下我们其实采用的是一个monorepo这样的一个东西那么这个细节展开其实我今天也不细说大家有兴趣可以翻到比如说老司机里面之前搜索一些之前发过的一些文章来看那么对monorepo而言它其实有一点非常或者说它对帮助特别大的事它对一些
不成熟以及高度融合偶合的codebase是特别有帮助的我为什么这么说呢就比如说我们去外面公司或者互联网公司去去去去求职或者面试的时候经常会问一个问题ok 你们怎么做模块化的对模块化之间怎么去做通信呢大家有没有想过一件事情为什么要问这个为什么要做这个呢其实很大的原因就是因为
通信这件事太常见了就比如说我们就是Ogv的这样一个模块他要去嵌入一个直播的一个广告而这件事情其实在我们的在我们的日常工作中太正常不过了但是我们使用偏模块化这样的一个思想强制让这两个模块不能互相调的强制不能互相调用以后我们需要通过一些buzz 啊root之类的东西去强行解欧解开
对那其实不是我们自己再给自己去添加这一些障碍吗那它的本质其实两个模块就要互相调整它就是业务的一部分为什么我们需要用一些偏RPC的一些手段把它隔离开了对那么在model report的同时其实我们也保留了一个传统的模式一个一个中心化的一个banner repository这样的一个一个结构我们会在像比如说左边每一个模块不管是粉色
或者是绿色或者蓝色的部分都会同时去向那个中心化的模块实际上说错了中心化的一个repository的registry去注册并且去分发那么我们一样比如说在我们mono-refo结构之外的有一些部分app依然是使用这种模式来工作的那么第二个我可能介绍的一个东西因为我今天主要会介绍三个时间嘛这是第二个时间第二个时间是我们的bapi那么在bapi的这个模型下
它是什么呢它其实是我们日常工作过程中最多的一件事情叫做说和后端去交流和后端去服务端去做通信那么我们一般比如说传统的怎么去通信呢我们口头的去跟服务端去进行一些协议删定当然大家很几乎每一个公司都会把它去落地成一个API的一个中心化的一个后台管理然后去描述我节森的key value结构是什么样子对我的一个rpc的pass
但是大家要思考想一件事情比如说我一个HTGP协议HTGP是一个篇广本的一个协议而这个协议上它自断放在哪它发在pass里面还是放在body里面还是放在哪个地方其实是HTGP协议都是不会去定义它的这也是类似比如RES4之类的这样的一些标准定出来的原因但是就是因为这么的自由所以我们的后端或者是客户端之间其实通信是一个
是一个高度自由但是不稳定的这样的一个状态可以好比于类似强类型员和弱类型员之间的一个区别那么B站怎么来解决呢?B站我们使用了一个标准的就是其实说实话就是照超Google API的GAPI我们定义了就是Protobufa的一套IDL我举个例子比如说我们有一个服务叫ServiceHGSNR这样的服务它有一个服务有一个IPC call
就是一个请求叫Tribolike,一键三连,对,也欢迎大家一键三连,他的输入很简单,一个Request,然后输出是一个Response。那在比如说B站的一个时间下来,我们会通过这个Protot的IDL,因为我们是中信化管理的那个库,所以它会做到Single Source唯一一份语言,通过这一份语言,我们会分别深沉对应端的,比如说客户端Client的Color。
以及服务上的口译那比如说这下面我贴的就是两段呃从我其实因为也无所谓所以我从我们项目里直接摘出来分别两段基于kt和swift的color的那个生成器以及那个我们购后端的一个一个口译的一个一个一个stop的一个函数入口那在这个模型下我们审我们节省出来了什么东西节省出来了没有
没不需要就是前后端去写任何code来做中间的一个数据data的转换以及高度的数据一致性对好那第三个我介绍的一个例子是什么呢是一个当然这是刚才两个都是已经在已经完成谈对那第三个可能是目前我在推进的一个东西这个东西是什么呢就是这是我自己定义了几个关键词分别是第一model language先进的一个语言
那可能我们对应的是偏古老的,不管是加瓦几粒也很前进,加瓦非常前进,可能对比的时候OCC,C加加这样,C加几粒现在21什么也有,但是说我不用,还有包括一个声明式UIT,KTUI,加MVI,ModelViewIntent,加Dependency Inject一来注入,那通过这四项,我们其实这四个东西,
那我们来看一下大概这个范氏是怎么推进的因为iOS对应的可能是一些SwiftUI等等的一些基础这样但是我们用不了所以其实B站使用了是完全自己写的这样的一个状态所以我可能偏向以安卓的这样一个例子来做来具体其实iOS是和安卓这边目前是一个完全一个队的状态那Language这一层其实就是Full Kp
然后Decorative UI的话我们会使用就是包括刚才说的就是今年release的Jetpack Compose那NVI这一层是在Jetpack ViewModel上摸改当然这个我可能会多说一个点其实是安卓的或者说整个生态包括ViewModel的使用的正确性对都是比较正确的其实说实话很多IOS偏IOS方向的一些
工程师同学在viewmodel的一些理解上他还停留在早年的pumpmodel的一个基础上对然后最后一层di的话那么我们在安卓这一刻是bass基于就是hunter的框架我们会去写一套gripper对ls的话我们使用的是一个刚才说的一个字间框架类的一个组件ridole好然后我大概
刚才比较玄幻啊虚幻对我可能说一下这个这个玩意大概长什么样我们可以看到其实它的一个结构是比如说我们先看左边它我是因为刚才擠了安卓的例子我先拿swift的具体弹吧具体因为compose弹吧大家随数可见那么拿l4一个例子而言可以理解成这个方这个build或者这个viewbuilder其实就是swift ui里面的body那个那个结构对它可以通过生命式的一个
一个一个语法对去描述一个就是雷奥斯比如说是个button那么对他而言他的服务依赖是基于那个di做的那么他主要生命一个外部的一个依赖比如说有个类那么我们并没有非常激进的类似比如ARBNB的那个epoxy之类的这样的一些框架去把整个导航器 navigation 层面全部去那个那个声明说话
对,我们还是偏保守的去让大家更熟悉的使用一些基于Activity Fragment的一个结构去来做的一个自定页面那么我们回到比如说右边这边我会定义一个页面是Activity然后并且把这个Relay帐的一个Service去Export出来然后Export完了之后它的一个内部的一个根结不是根结内部的一个字节点其实就可以通过那个DI
去拿到这个相应的服务并且我们做了一些服务之间的一些传递等相关的一些东西好那么我刚才大概就是说了可能是在B站在移动端这边使用了三个思路来去解决刚才碰到的不管是现象啊等等这样一些东西然后快结束了嘛想说一些感悟就是我就很多
同學其實就是包括包括因為因為接觸很多同學他們的或者說工作的一個路徑或者說是怎麼說呢就是發展發展軌道都是去往一個架構式的這樣一個角色去去發展的一般就是要么是往架構式的角色要么往manager管理的一個角色對兩條路去走那比如說我自己認為或者說一個架構式他的工作樂趣是什麼
对那么工作乐趣我觉得就是比如说我也看到过很多网上有起一些大厂的一些呃价购师在那聊比如说他们的设计的价购然后怎么把价购自己去拆到小价购室上然后对等等这样的一些日常工作我感觉这个工作跟manager很像对感觉不好玩啊那我觉得一个价购师的乐趣可能是个什么东西呢
對這個這個這個這個這個翻教工作細胞有個有個有個翻教工作細胞對就像我們人體裡面每一個都有就比如說我們去驗血我們得病了我們去驗血我們驗血我們就知道我們得大概身上得了什麼病為什麼呢因為我們身上的每一個細胞就像人體的比如說九大系統什麼循環系統啊什麼什麼什麼各種系統它系統它自己就有一個自治區能力就像我剛才說到的
自动化一切每个系统它自己就可以管理好一些东西非常神奇而一个架构的乐趣是什么我认为就是去设计这样的一些自寻环系统能让这些系统在互相之间非常融洽的运行起来并且达到比如说我们一个商业公司的这种目的对这是其实是我自己个人认为的一个架构的一个乐趣然后我放一个视频对
因为在B站我放了一个我自己比较喜欢的两个UP主一个是饭市对饭具的一个是房子塔服这个视频大家请看一下
随后几个小时内身体内大部分细胞也会由于氧气供应中断而满满死亡死后30分钟大部分脏气也会衰竭从而无法再作为气管移植工体由于免疫失效肠道和表皮的细菌会大距离
战斗五行中性力细胞会一直战斗到最后一刻直至全军服务同时严正反应会让血效板逐渐将全身的红细胞中粘成血栓12小时内人体绝大多数细胞都会坏死无论身体湿水受缩毛放和支架会显得似乎长长了一些最后停止工作的可能是沉鲜为细胞这些细胞平时主要负责行政摊痕修复身体损伤或是包裹工作他们在死后的两三天时间里依然会保留一定的细胞活性徒劳地继续待命准备
修复伤口哇 真的是代入感太强我已经开始痛了所以为了不让体内的细胞遭遇这份苦楚大家一定要多注意身体健康啊ok 其实这样的当然第一一个我已经那个视频最后一句大家注意身体健康成选对自己好的一点那另外一个简直是什么呢就是架构啊架构本身他一定是有自己的声明周期的就是一定不要去想着说ok我做了一个什么样子的一个循环系统
做了一個這樣的系統它可以保醫生不可能的它最好的面臨了一個結果就是它被光榮淘汰然後得到淨化一直淨化一直淨化下去這樣子的話其實不管是一個一個軟件系統又或者說是一個企業上的一個系統它才能得到無限的淨化就像我們人類終於淨化到了生物鏈的頂端對OK然後最後我分享兩個公眾號碼第一個實際是B站
对开源的东西其实是不少的而且我自己认为还是质量还不错的对这个大家可以在比较关注一下第二个其实是我们B站的一个一个卫星公众号一个技术号对好最后我发了一些就说刚才在过程中翻到的一些一些句子的一些摘录和一些资源相关的一些东西大家可以后续去自己翻越来看好我就讲到这谢谢大家